بالنسبه لمرحله التخدير تمت في همم امام
الساعه السابعه و 55 دقيقه بدخول التوامين
لغرف العمليات وتم تخدير كل طفل على حدى
البدايه ثم وضع الانابيب التنفس والقاصرات
الحيويه وقاصات الشريانيه
ولله الحمد تمت المرحله في ساعه ونصف قبل
الوقت المحدد اللي هو مخصص لها ساعتين
وتمت بثلاثه المؤشرات الحيويه للطفلين
الحمد لله مستقره همم طبعا همم نوه عمليه
التخدير مستمره نهايه العمليه هي بس
المراحل الاولى هي بدايه همم
الان احنا في الملح الرابع يعني اللي هي
مرحله فصل الامعاء والكبد وهمم وتم وضع
الصبغه اثناء عمليه تحديد مجرى قنوات همم
وعصاره همم الصفراويه لكل الطفلين الحمد
لله سوف ننتقل اليك السؤال ولكن دعنا
نشاهد ايضا ومش همم ويكون معي مشاهدي قناه
العربيه للمرحله الرابعه التي تتم الان
كما تذكرت ان الدكتور عبدالله الروبيه
وايضا الدكتور عبد الله النمشان والطاقه
الطبي الان يقوم يقومون بفصل او عمليه
الفصل وهي من المراحل الحساسه خاصه ان تتم
عمليه الفصل كما تحدث الدكتور نزار وكذلك
قبل ذلك الدكتور عبد الله ربيعه والدكتور
محمد النمشان عن ان تتم عمليه الفصل من
همم مرحله الكبد وهي فصل الكبد وكذلك ايضا
سوف تنتقل وتستمر خلال ساعه ونصف همم سوف
انتقل اليك يا دكتور نزار ايضا في سؤال
اخر بعد هذه العمليه ما الذي سوف يجري من
مراحل همم اخرى
همم
فصل الكبد ولامعاء همم وبعدين فصلت هذه
المرحله الرابعه
تتم في هذه المرحله اللي هو فصل الامعاء
الكبد بعدين فصح الجدار الخلفي لا ما في
عظام الجدار الخلفي همم
بعدين يضع وضع على كرسي على حدا من كل طفل
على حدا وتبدا عمليه الترميم
والاربطه والتجميل يعني الفصل التام او
فصل التوام السيامي تتم في هذه
وكل نظام كل طفل يكون فيه حذاء
وبعدها تتم عمليات همم اعاده الترميم
والامعاء
والكبد وهمم
الحلقه الاخيره التلاميم ولا الضمادات
يعني تكون مرحله الخطيره المهمه يعني
نعم شكرا لك الدكتور نزار اذا طاقم الطبي
في مستشفى الملك عبدالله التخصصي بوزاره
الحرس الوطني همم نستطيع ان نقول انه يقوم
الان باجراء اصعب واخطر مرحله من المراحل
الست لفصل التوام السيامي عمر وعلي وهي
مرحله عمليه فصل الكبد وكذلك فصل الجدار
ليتم وضع كل طفل على حده وتتم الان
وتستغرق ساعه ونصف ساعه